- You guys all had pretty iconic looks.
Everybody up here, back in the day
but here are some I wanna show.
So, Danny, this is great.
- Aw.
- [Danny] Wow.
- Look at you.
How cute.
Look I dressed today-
- Aw.
to try and fit in, with these.
- [Audience] Aw!
- Oh, Danny.
- Yeah, God, I look crazy.
Are there any looks that you'd prefer
never to see again?
Just curious.
- [Danny] I mean, I
didn't mind that last one.
This one's okay.
We look alright.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
I think you cool as hell!
- [Danny] Not bad.
- [Kelly] I have a ton
I wish I'd never done
(Kelly laughing)
- Geez.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] I'm like, what?
That's so awesome.
I mean, so much style.
It was.
- [Man] That's when we
were chasing Salt-N-Pepa
- [Kelly] I love, yeah
I love that you were on top.
- We chased them everywhere.
- We were wearing our merch.
(laughing together)
- Oh my God.
Do you ever, okay do you do that though?
Because I sometimes,
like I have this song
called, "Love So Soft"
and there's a sweatshirt of mine
and they made it really soft.
And I just really love
wearing it because it's soft
but I have to like wear it
around my house cause I'm like,
what am I gonna show
up with my name on me?
- [Cheryl] Right, right.
- And maybe I will.
Maybe I will.
- Why not? Why not?
- [Kelly] Yeah, I like-
- I always wondered about that.
- [Kelly] I like it's like,
I love how soft it is.
Anyway.